hey everyone its Alicia Malone I'm here
at the premiere of the mummy in New York
this is the first film in the new dark
universe series and though it's dark and
stormy outside all the fans have been
lining up two hours for see Tom Cruise
meanwhile I want Tom to show me the
mummy
[Music]
I know you love monster movies what is
it about the genre that fascinates you
you know it's just big cinema I think
it's you know you can when you have an
audience and you have scares and you can
create that kind of suspense it really
allows very unique kind of character
drama and comedy and just a way to
entertain an audience in a very unique
way and one way to think so mummy is a
good way into the whole dark universe
I just love the age-old stories it just
lends itself to such an amazing visual
reference as well as adventure and
ghosts and yeah it's just such a I think
it was just such an organic one to start
with good stories are often retold what
is it about the story of the mummy that
keeps it fascinating I think the fact
that it's a woman mummy
yeah really freshens it up and the story
is just tremendous I love action - yeah
and I can tell when a great story and
great action come together and this was
it way to see you singing I'm very proud
of moving to the moment and I'm proud to
be a part of it and part of my breakfast
and living his strong powerful role to a
woman and I'm humbled and he chose me
for it and and yeah I'm excited for the
movies that are either empowering woman
she's a woman who was promised power she
was told she was going to lead she was
betrayed by the man she trusts most her
father and now she feels he can take
back what she deserves and I thought
very interesting you know no matter how
far over into the dark side she goes I
was one of the audience to root for and
connector yo Feder quick than anyone to
tell me about the magic of Tom Cruise
what does he bring to every single
project he brings like 200% I mean he is
so ridiculously talented and then he
works harder than anybody else he's so
funny and charming and his characters
are always so interesting you just can't
stop watching his
it's it's time phrase it is bent and you
have these powerful characters look it's
sofia boutella is the mummy she's
beautiful she's terrifying
you're both can't take your eyes off her
and you want to run from right you know
because a movie
it's an origin story but it's kind of
melodrama and drama that you can create
in this kind of world and I'm really
excited about the dark universe yes
thank you I mean the money and you can
see the mummy in theaters now
[Music]